[Musique]
alors c'est super gentil de m'accueillir
ce soir j'ai l'impression que vous êtes
tous à l'aise bah moi pas vraiment à
vrai dire parce que je vais vous dire
personnellement je suis arachnophobe je
suis claustrophobe je suis accrophone
alors c'est vrai que c'est pas c'est pas
évident de se présenter de cette manière
là mais je vous rassure à partir du
moment où on est capable d'identifier
ces vulnérabilités en fait vous êtes
déjà sur le chemin pour révéler votre
vrai nature là vous avez le plus
potentiel et donc le plus d'impact
possible en Occident on n'a pas
l'habitude de se présenter de cette
manière là par contre en Asie beaucoup
plus un petit peu comme ce que vous avez
ici qui est le kinsugi en fait on va
sublimer les cicatrices de la vie en
révélant justement ces fractures pour
révéler la personnalité des personnes
c'est utilisé en psychologie c'est aussi
utiliser dans l'art comme vous voyez là
une poterie fêlée on va la révéler par
l'intermédiaire d'un filet d'or qui va
sublimer l'arc que vous voyez ici alors
du coup ben ouais je n'aime pas les
araignées je n'ouvre jamais un
dictionnaire à la lettre A si utilise un
sac de couchage il est toujours ouvert
sur le côté et puis je fais ce que je
peux quand je marche sur un pont et
jouer parce que ça me fait peur donc du
coup à partir de là je vous ai identifié
les situations dans lesquelles je
redoute mais du coup ça me permet
d'identifier aussi les situations dans
lesquelles je me sens le plus à l'aise
donc ce soir je vais me mettre à l'aise
mais je vous rassure je vais simplement
m'asseoir
waouh
alors déjà d'ici le point de vue est
différent je me rapproche beaucoup plus
là des gens qui sont du premier rang je
vois un peu plus leurs expressions sur
leur visage il y en a pour certains qui
ont l'air surpris alors faut que je
fasse gaffe quand même avec les lumières
d'autres peut-être amusés d'autres
encore plutôt impassible alors je vous
rassure ça dépend du vécu et ça dépend
des du contexte dans lequel on se situe
et ben je vais justement utiliser ce
contexte là ou plutôt la situation la
posture pour vous exprimer un peu les
propos de la thématique de ce soir je
vais vous raconter une histoire il y a 4
ans de cela à peu près j'ai été mandaté
par une ONG pour faire une expertise
scientifique dans un village reculer au
Togo sur un système qui capte collecte
et stocke de l'eau donc on est dans un
village reculé on est à 1h30 à peu près
de la petite ville la plus proche en
moto brousse il y a pas d'électricité il
y a pas de réseau d'eau il y a pas de
réseau de d'assainissement et donc je
suis allé dans ce village
j'ai été accueilli par le chef du
village et les membres du Conseil on a
d'abord fait une cérémonie
traditionnelle dans lequel on fait appel
aux esprits des anciens pour savoir si
ma venue était bénéfique ou non et
ensuite on a fait la Réunion donc vous
avez une photographie ici de cette
réunion qui a eu lieu il y a 4 ans de
cela donc on a fait la Réunion on ne
peut plus normal et puis à la fin donc
tout le monde se lève pour sortir de la
salle donc là je me lève
et puis en fait il y a quelqu'un qui m'a
interpellé dans le fond de la salle donc
je suis allé voir cette personne qui
était assise apparemment en situation de
handicap problème de jambes et problèmes
de bras donc moi naturellement pour
discuter avec cette personne je m'assois
comme je l'ai fait tout à l'heure sans
prêter attention aux personnes au regard
des personnes qui avaient dans cette
salle bien ça fait quatre ans maintenant
que je retourne dans ce village parce
qu'on a un projet d'agro-développement
avec les villageois et d'ailleurs
j'emmène avec moi à tous les ans des
élèves ingénieurs de l'Université de
technologie on en est à la quatrième
édition et puis en fait le fait de
m'asseoir comme ça devant cette personne
c'était le déclencheur ça a été la clé
qui a scellé le lien de confiance en
cette communauté et moi et c'est depuis
qu'on arrive à générer justement un
projet en agroécologie avec ce village
c'est le début c'est le déclencheur de
l'effet papillon dont je vous parle ce
soir alors on pourrait résumer ce qui
s'est passé par un seul mot
c'est pas quelque chose qu'on a
l'habitude d'utiliser dans le domaine
des technologies et pourtant c'est
fondamental pourquoi j'allais dire de la
techno pour de la techno ça ne sert mais
strictement à rien vous allez concevoir
des systèmes qui sont ultra complexes
des systèmes qui sont complètement à
l'opposé contre-productif par rapport
aux enjeux sociétaux fait par des gens
il est responsables pour moi
personnellement si la profonde paraisse
intellectuelle aucune pitié envers ces
personnes ou ses entreprises mais il
faut quand même laisser une porte de
sortie pour essayer d'améliorer les
choses alors entrer dans un processus
d'empathie comme ça c'est une prise de
risque parce que nécessairement vous
allez vous confronter à des blocages et
des inerties qu'elles soient culturelles
scientifiques ou autres et pour essayer
de comprendre un petit peu comment ça
fonctionne je vais faire référence à une
personne
cette personne c'est celui-ci celui vous
voyez assis là derrière moi sur un tapis
c'est mon mentor c'est le professeur
Anil Kumar goupta donc qui professeur à
l'Indian institut of management donc on
Inde ça fait 40 ans qui navigue dans les
coins les plus reculés de l'Inde pour
aller rencontrer les populations les
plus pauvres au moment où c'est le plus
difficile pour elle et il essaie
d'extraire de la part de ses populations
toutes les idées créatives que ces
personnes peuvent avoir très peu de
ressources mais très grande créativité
par intermédiaire de son réseau le honey
binetwork il diffuse après le plus
globalement possible en Inde et à
l'étranger sécrétivité réalisée par ces
personnes vulnérables et bien je vais
vous demander d'écouter je vais vous
faire passer un petit passage vidéo
quand on l'a fait venir en France il y a
quelques années en arrière donc là c'est
un extrait d'une vidéo qu'on a fait au
Palais du Luxembourg au Sénat et je vous
demande de bien écouter
je vais reprendre un petit peu ce que
Annie vient de dire when I feel your pen
as you feel it is
my pen ça veut dire tout simplement que
si je ressens la souffrance telle que
toi tu la ressens elle ne reste plus ta
souffrance elle devient la mienne et du
coup je suis plus capable de comprendre
quels sont tes besoins pour pouvoir
concevoir un système technologique qui
soit en parfaite adéquation avec
justement ce besoin cette communauté
avec les ressources du territoire et
bien si de cette manière là qu'on va
aborder effectivement l'effet papillon
et là ce que je vais vous raconter
maintenant c'est comment mais ça en
pratique parce que c'est pas évident
donc on reprend un petit peu en arrière
la posture que j'ai eu de là au Togo
dans ce village je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure on emmène des étudiants chaque
année en 2021 on n'a pas pu à cause de
la situation
covid covid-19 donc du coup on est parti
de 10 mois après mais pendant ces 10
mois il fallait qu'on bosse on devait
récupérer de l'information sur
l'agriculture biologique parce que c'est
un projet on agroécologie qu'on a au
Togo et donc du coup on s'est dit ben on
va capter de l'information avec les
petites fermes qu'on a ici en France et
on allait on va aller à leur rencontre
pour mettre en application ce processus
d'empathie il faut d'abord réfléchir et
savoir c'est quoi c'est fermé en France
on agriculture bio trois
caractéristiques principales la première
il travaille avec le climat 24 heures
sur 24 ils ont les pieds sur terre 24
heures sur 24 on se lance pas comme le
sens figuré leur lieu de vie c'est aussi
leur lieu de travail et 3 ils font super
attention à leurs impacts
environnementaux pas d'intran chimique
beaucoup de processus de recyclage et
puis
autonomie énergétique et aussi de
l'autoconstruction pour complètement
maîtriser leur outil de production pour
aller à la rencontre de ces gens là en
fait il y avait qu'une seule solution
possible c'était celle là
allez à leur rencontre à pied donc oui
effectivement j'ai fait 1000 km à leur
rencontre à pied 23 fermes tout était
planifié six mois à l'avance et le fait
d'avoir utilisé ce processus immersif
d'aller à la rencontre j'avais moi-même
les pieds sur terre le climat 24 heures
sur 24 minimiser mes impacts
environnementaux il était hors de
question que j'aille chez eux et que
j'aille branché mon pc sur sur leur
ligne électrique j'étais totalement en
autonomie énergétique panneau solaire
batterie de stockage tout ça derrière
mon chariot 30 kg
mais ça c'est super bien passé alors
c'est pas tant moi qui est important
là-dedans mais c'est ce processus a
permis n'acceptabilité de la part des
fermiers qui est absolument
extraordinaire là on voit par exemple
Frédéric au sein de cette ferme qui
s'appelle au gré du temps une ferme
absolument prodigieuse il n'en que un
hectare de foncier agricole et dégage
trois salaires et cette entreprise là
quand on parle de vulnérabilité ou
d'événements perturbateurs non pour eux
c'est à chaque fois un moyen de trouver
une solution pour aller encore beaucoup
plus loin donc ça permet des rencontres
absolument fabuleuses si je n'avais pas
fait ce parcours à pied j'aurais fait un
truc de chercheurs dans son bureau en
téléphonant totalement
inutile donc il est vraiment une
pertinence à visualiser les travaux de
recherche et l'impact que ça peut
générer par derrière la deuxième la
deuxième partie va concerner en fin de
compte une suite de ça en fait quand
j'ai fait ces 1000 km il y a un
entrepreneur local et citoyen qui me dit
j'aime bien ta façon de faire et merci
d'aller au plus proche de la population
et bien on va travailler ensemble pour
travailler notamment avec des quartiers
propriétaire de la ville de Troie
quartier prioritaire c'est quoi c'est un
quartier dont les la vie
socio-économique est beaucoup plus
difficile que la moyenne des autres des
autres personnes dans la ville les qpv
quartier prioritaire de la politique de
la ville donc pour les rencontrer ces
gens-là on est en train de mettre en
place une micro ferme urbaine
permaculturelle et citoyenne avec la
population il faut aller les rencontrer
pour comprendre vraiment leurs besoins
donc vous avez vu ici un certain nombre
d'images le premier processus c'était
quoi c'était la rencontre allez à la
rencontre des associations
collectivités bien sûr et autres
organismes qui gravitent autour des
quartiers prioritaires mais ça je
considère que c'est une approche trop
surfacique il faut aller beaucoup plus
proche de la population donc du coup
j'ai décidé tous les vendredis matin
d'aller au club de couture de ce
quartier pour aller rencontrer des
femmes du quartier alors pourquoi le
club de couture alors déjà un petit
bonjour à Rachida qui la présidente de
l'association la map qui se club de
couture qui jambe aussi avec des cours
de français c'est Didier a des personnes
qui arrivent sur le territoire dont la
langue maternelle n'est pas le français
pour la petite histoire le club de
couture parce qu'en fait bon je suis
tombé dans le chaudron la couture quand
j'étais petit ma mère était couturière
donc moi évidemment je savais coudre je
suis le monsieur couture à la maison et
ne rigolez pas mais à l'époque où j'ai
passé le bac j'ai pris option couture ça
existait je n'ai eu que un point
peut-être mais malgré tout ça quand même
fonctionné et ben le fait c'est ça qui a
créé le lien avec avec cette population
tous les vendredis matin on discutait
beaucoup on prenait le thé ensemble
c'était ça très convivial il y avait un
grand un échange vraiment génial entre
elle elle et moi vraiment un processus
gagnant-gagnant on travaillait aussi je
tiens à le préciser et du coup c'est ce
qui nous a permis de mettre en place
depuis plus d'un an on a 6 personnes du
quartier prioritaire qui est pas loin
d'ici qui sont collaborateurs bénévole
de l'UTT parce que leur expertise de vie
au sein de ce territoire et aussi
pertinente des chercheurs qui a des
compétences spécifiques donc en les
intégré dans le projet de recherche qui
aujourd'hui est en train de décimer un
petit peu parce que du coup ben on a une
école une école élémentaire qui vient de
se brancher sur le projet et ainsi de
suite on arrive à SMS au fur et à mesure
l'effet papillon continue au fur et à
mesure de cette posture togolaise on est
passé par la suite à un projet lié avec
les 1000 km qui lui-même est en train de
dériver sur un projet du territoire ici
en France pour SMS sur les quartiers
prioritaires puisqu'on espère que ça va
pouvoir se reproduire alors j'allais
dire alors il y a des choses que je vous
ai pas montré mais c'est vrai que il
manquait quelque chose là quand j'ai
quand j'y allais moi dans le dans le
cours de couture c'était pas encore
suffisant parce que là je ne voyais en
fait que la vie entre 8h et 18h mais il
y a quelque chose avant il y a quelque
chose après donc avec le partenariat de
3 au Babita le bailleur social ben voilà
j'ai vécu pendant un mois dans le dans
le quartier spartiate c'est juste un
appart vide j'avais mon sac de couchage
ouvert sur le côté et puis mon vélo pour
monter et descendre les escaliers comme
font beaucoup les gens du quartier et là
du coup rien que ça avec quelqu'un
d'immeuble on s'est dit c'est vrai que
j'avais mal à l'épaule porter le vélo
avec la barre etc on a simplement pris
des anciennes bandoulières de sac à dos
on a fait ça on l'a monté on l'a mis sur
l'épaule et du coup ça simplifiait la
montée et la descente durant le durant
le matin et le soir
ce que j'essaie de vous faire exprimer
ce soir c'est que en fin de compte
c'est avant tout un message d'amour moi
que je vous envoie que je vous envoie ce
soir
acceptez vos vulnérabilités pour
vraiment révéler votre vraie nature pour
avoir le plus de potentiel possible et
impacter et notamment et créer du lien
notamment avec les populations générales
parce que je vous garantis que la
richesse que l'on récolte en allant à la
rencontre de ces personnes-là ne
serait-ce que pour leur dire mais tu
vois le petit truc que tu as fait
peut-être que toi tu considères que
c'est pas grand chose mais multiplie le
diffuses le plus loin possible et là tu
vas voir que ça va avoir de très gros
impacts c'est ce qu'on essaie de faire
avec nos petits moyens de vieillir d'une
certaine façon et puis ben voilà
l'interaction qu'on a eu ce soir pas
longtemps 15 minutes à tout casser moi
sur déjà c'est un impact sur moi pour
vous je sais pas pas nécessairement tout
de suite dans quelques jours dans
quelques mois et peut-être que je suis
un peu naïf mais je crois vraiment
l'effet papillon et j'espère que cet
effet papillon pourra générer je veux
dire un ouragan de créativité pour une
société plus soutenable merci à vous
tous bonne soirée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]